this misunderstanding of the left which
thinks that crime exists because there's
law enforcement rather than the other
way around that's why they burned down a
Wendy's on Saturday night in Atlanta so
you probably saw the scenes there was
this fire engulfed the whole Wendy's in
the middle of Atlanta on Saturday why
did they do it they did it because the
cops use deadly force against a criminal
against a black man that was the racial
aspect of it which is the reason they
tied into all of the riots and why why
the Wendy's burned down well what
actually happened during that
altercation the way it's being portrayed
is that cops went up to a man who is
simply sleeping in the parking lot and
these cops Prost certainly stone-cold
racists killed the man for no reason is
that what really happened no how do we
know that that's not what happened we
have body cam footage and we have
security camera footage let's take a
look I think you've had too much to
drink to be dry this put you hands upon
your back for me okay and there the guy
he breaks out he's got two cops on him
trying to arrest him and this guy
clearly pretty strong busts out it's
already pretty clear he's drunk or on
drugs he's on the ground the two cops
are trying to subdue him but they're not
using a lot of different techniques
presumably because if the cops use too
much force they're gonna have their
lives completely destroyed they're going
to be accused of racism and we've used
to all these things right so this guy
obviously strong as an ox is basically
tossing these two cops around finally he
gets up steals the cops taser
now still running away no use of force
turns around pulls the Taser on the cops
possibly [ __ ] looks like he shoots weed
I don't know if he shoots or not but
does look that way and then the cops
discharged their weapons and get him on
the ground very sad scene why is it a
sad scene it's a sad scene because a man
died why did a man die did he die
because a bunch of racist cops went out
hunting him and shooting him down or did
he die because he was committing a crime
and threatening the lives of those
police officers stealing their weapons
and then unfortunately very sadly had to
be put down himself obviously it's the
latter
the ultimate reason that this is a sad
scene the ultimate reason that this man
died is because crime is a very sad
thing there's no there's no win here
right what's the win I mean I guess the
win is more people didn't die
I guess the win is there is some justice
but it's sad to watch nobody wants that
those two cops did not want to kill that
guy how do we know they didn't wanna
kill that guy because they wrestled him
they used every bit of non-lethal force
that they could have four minutes
beforehand and then he pulls their taser
and they still don't use force then he
turns around and points it at them I I
think pulls the trigger it's kind of
hard to see on the camera very sad stuff
and yet not one thing the cops did was
inappropriate if anything they were
timid in their use of force ostensibly
because of the environment that we're in
right now then a bunch of rioters burned
down the windi's why'd they burn down
the Wendy's there I could see them
burning down the police station if they
felt this was unjust even though it
manifestly wasn't unjust you just heard
it you just saw it but let's say even
the the rioters didn't look at that tape
so they didn't know that the killing was
perfectly appropriate albeit sad what
what did the Wendy's do what did that
did the the manager of the Wendy's
participate in this no not at all
this burning this rioting has nothing to
do with justice okay no one could watch
that footage and conclude that that was
police brutality and the people who
burned down the Wendy's don't care about
the truth or justice they just want to
burn stuff down
[Music]
you
[Music]